so we have the latest jobs numbers and once
again the latest jobs for it has missed expectations.
But I want to talk about it
typically in order really to have a conversation.
Um, I want to make more of an effort to go
beyond just the latest numbers and to really
make sure we're understanding the big issues
that are underlying these jobs numbers and
the systemic economic problems that are going
to have to be solved if we're really going
to progress as a society and progress as an
economy for the sort of betterment and wellbeing
of everybody in the country, on the planet,
whatever.
So as a starting point, let's quickly deal
with the not at the numbers themselves.
New Jobs, again, have slowed down.
They fell short of expected numbers in May
only 75,000 jobs were added in May.
The expected number was 175,000 so number
one, it's really important to understand that
because more and more people live in the United
States over time and based on their ages,
the number of working age people also fluctuates.
But as a really general idea, you need to
create some new jobs just to keep up with
population growth.
There are different estimates of what that
number is.
I've seen as low as 80,000 jobs a month.
I've seen as high as 120,000 jobs a month,
eight of complex and pretty widely contested
number and I know no matter what number arrange
I give, some people are going to disagree
with me, but understand the concept.
If 75,000 new jobs were created and you need
80,000 or a hundred thousand or 120,000 just
to account for population growth, we're falling
behind one way or the other.
The only debate is how much are we falling
behind when we only create 75,000 jobs.
Now the trendline is also a concern because
we got below expected numbers for several
months in a row.
The numbers from March were revised down from
the initial reports.
March was initially reported at one 89,000
and then the numbers were fine tuned and we
found out it was actually 153,000 new jobs
in March, which is in great April, was reported
as 263,000.
It was fine tuned.
And then it turns out it was actually only
224,000 new jobs.
So unemployment is at a historically low rate,
a new job.
Numbers are falling short of expectations
regularly.
Now payrolls have ticked up slightly, but
less than inflation, which is an important
metric to consider.
So if we step back and we say, how is the
Trump jobs economy, it's more or less the
trend line that we saw under Obama with some
slow down.
It's basically a very similar trajectory except
it is slowing down to some degree.
Now how much of it is because of Trump?
Some but not all.
Uh, uh, some of what Donald Trump has done
is already certainly having an effect on the
broader economic conditions.
And then stepping back from that, there's
sort of like a broader geopolitical, a circumstance
that, um, exists not in a vacuum but sort
of on a continuum.
And that has carried on from the Obama presidency
into the Trump presidency.
Now let's get to the really important stuff
because everything I've told you so far, it's
important to know, but tracking these numbers
will not and does not address the real problems
that we have in the United States around working
and labor and wages.
I'll give you an example.
Here's a problem.
A ton of work in our economy is assigned no
economic value and is treated as such, which
has a whole number of different effects.
So if you stay home to raise kids or you take
care of elderly parents instead of working
or you volunteer in work, that strengthens
our communities in ways that don't have a
specifically assigned economic value, but
obviously have value to the economy.
If kids aren't raised in a good way to use
a really sort of vague general term.
If kids aren't raised in a way that makes
them a good members of our communities that
has an economic costs, they are more likely
to commit crime, which costs money in terms
of police and property damage and whatever
else.
So you can understand how raising kids properly
has an economic value, but it's hard to exactly
assign a number to it.
And if you can't do that in our economy, it's
effectively valued at zero.
That's a major problem.
That's not addressed by looking at did we
have 150,000 or 200,000 jobs created issue
number two.
Even when we look at wage growth, whether
we have 0.2% wage growth or 5% or we annualize
it to three, four or 5% wage growth or whatever,
and we look at the numbers over the last 40
years, what you have to understand is that
the lion's share of the mean wage growth that
has taken place over the last many decades
has gone disproportionately to the top.
Almost all of the economic gains since 1980
have gone to the top half of earners rather
than the bottom half of earners.
A ton of it has gone to the top 1% a crazy
disproportionate amount has gone to the top
0.1% so you can argue about Trump has oh 0.5%
wage growth and Obama had oh 0.4 or whatever.
But if most of it goes to the rich, it's not
stimulating the economy as much as it could.
It's making society more unequal, which increases
crime and all sorts of other that needs to
be solved.
So the point I'm trying to make to you is
that bragging about were up 0.2% in wages
or the unemployment rate has ticked up or
down 0.1% or 150,000 versus 160,000 job creation.
It doesn't deal with these longterm systemic
problems that when members of Congress are
reelected every two years when presidents
are reelected every four years and senators
are reelected every six, there is no sort
of of a, a baseline incentive to actually
deal with that.
And by the way, the political battle over
the jobs reports doesn't touch inequality.
It doesn't touch work that's valued at zero
by the economy and none of it deals with automation
and technological unemployment and the fact
that we're going to have to rethink human
relationships to work.
There are a ton of ideas around how do we
think about a technological unemployment and
automation and robotics and artificial intelligence.
We've heard about universal basic income.
We've heard about a government guaranteed
jobs programs, negative income tax rates.
The most important question is going to be
who gets the gains from technology.
If nothing changes in our economic system
and we know the answer, the huge corporations
and the rich people who buy the robots and
the automation technology and the artificial
intelligence infrastructures, they are going
to get the gains which is going to make the
country more unequal.
It's not going to do demand side stimulus,
meaning giving people money that they can
spend, uh, imagine a company with a hundred
employees and the technology that lets them
double productivity.
There are lots of ways to distribute the gains.
A pure capitalism solution might be the company
fires 50 people and they're able to keep producing
the same amount of stuff with half the employees
because of this great technology, it's terrible
for the economy.
50 people are now out of a job.
They don't have money with which they can
go and buy things from other companies.
So those other companies that want to be selling
stuff to those 50 people blues out and those
other companies end up having to let people
go.
So that's not good.
Like a pure free market capitalism solution
for technological unemployment and automation
technology is not good.
The employer could also say, instead of firing
50 people, we'll keep all hundred people,
but now with this new technology that doubles
productivity, each employee only has to work
20 hours a week instead of 40 hours a week
and they can all keep making the same amount
of money and the capitalists, so to speak,
the ownership, the business doesn't get any
of the gains.
Now companies aren't going to do that.
A fair solution would be that the company
gets a little bit of those games because they're
buying the new technology.
But the workers also get some of it.
I don't know exactly what the numbers would
be, but that would be sort of a solution from
the world of social democracy.
But as you can see, there has to be regulation
in order to prevent the company from just
taking all the gains and firing half of their
workforce.
And that's just one of the problems that needs
to be solved.
So my message to you today is that we can't
take any politician seriously that isn't talking
about the deeper issues, job creation numbers,
unemployment rates, wage growth, these ideas
of we're going to bring back manufacturing.
These are surface issues that if we solve,
are effectively bandaids in our economic system.
If a candidate isn't talking about restructuring
the economic system, changing the relationship
of humans to work, dealing with inequality
in a serious way, dealing with the economic
activities that are not valued at all by our
current economy.
Uh, and then also by the way, dealing with
activities that are profitable for lots of
people, but actually aren't economically valuable.
If you look at a ton of what the financial
worlds derivative instruments and speculation
do, they can't actually be taken seriously
as drivers of economic value in a longterm
way.
A lot of that stuff that's going on on Wall
Street merely serves to enrich people without
actually providing any stimulus to the economy.
So if politicians aren't talking about that
stuff, if they're talking merely about, I'll
bring back, uh, of, of manufacturing jobs
or whatever else, I don't take them seriously
and you shouldn't take them seriously either.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at the pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman.